[Musik]
gelblich heißt eigentlich dass es wie
soll ich sagen das ist schon fast schon
ranzig ist aber zu grünen darf es auch
nicht sein da benutzen viele nämlich die
Blätter genau da machen Trick um
Olivenöl so auszusehen lassen dass es
aus der Früh Ernte ist und zwar presst
man einfach die Blätter mit und das sind
auch Schwebeteilchen drin das ist auch
ein bisschen gefährlich wenn im Olivenöl
Schwebeteilchen drin sind dann wird es
auch schneller ranzig habe ich recht bei
uns wird es gut gefällt hat genau das
heißt wir hätten jetzt auch zwei drei
Monate noch warten können hätten ganz
viel Olivenöl herstellen können dass wir
noch mehr haben aber wir haben jetzt
gesagt nee wir nehmen jetzt wieder die
früh Ernte deswegen sind wir jetzt auch
recht früh da und haben lieber weniger
Olivenöl aber dafür das beste
[Musik]